[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تتواصل المباحثات في جناف بين
وزيري الخارجيه الامريكي جون كيري والروسي
سيرجي لافروف بشان مبادره موسكو الخاصه
بتفكيك الاسلحه الكيميائيه السوريه وهي
المبادره التي اعلن الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد انه لن يلتزم بها الا اذا اوقفت
واشنطن تهديدها لسوريا ودعمها للارهابيين
على حد تعبيره نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في
محورين ما فرص التوافق بين موسكو والغرب
بشان صيغه تطبيق المبادره الروسيه بخصوص
سوريا والى اي حد يمكن ان تؤثر الخلافات
بشان المبادره في تحديد تعامل دمشق معها
ليس من المؤكد بعد ما اذا كانت مباحثات
وزيري الخارجيه الامريكي جون كيري والروسي
سيرجي لافروف بشان مبادره موسكو لتفكيك
اسلحه دمشق الكيميائيه ستنتهي خلال يومي
الخميس والجمعه ام انها قد تمتد الى يوم
السبت لكن ما لا شك فيه ان هذه المباحثات
لن تكون سهله باي حال بالنظر الى حجم
الشكوك والاشتراطات التي احاطت بالمبادره
الروسيه منذ طرحها قبل ثلاثه
ايام جون كيري في جنيف قبل وصول نظيره
الروسي سيرغي لافروف بنحو سبع ساعات يوان
وربما اكثر من المحادثات لبحث المبادره
التي فجرتها موسكو يوم الاثنين يتضمن كل
وفد في سويسرا خبراء في الاسلحه
الكيميائيه استنادا لصحيفه كوميرسانت
الروسيه ينص المقترح على اربع نقاط انضمام
سوريا الى منظمه حظر الاسلحه الكيميائ
اعلان سوريا عن مواقع تخزين هذه الاسلحه
وتقديم معلومات مفصله عن برنامجها
الكيميائي السماح للمفتشين الدوليين
بالتحقيق يحدد المفتشون بعدها طريقه تدمير
تلك الاسلحه في حال موافقه الجميع على هذه
النقاط ودون اي مفاجات قد تستغرق العمليه
ما لا يقل عن شهر كحد ادنى قبيل بدء
المحادثات الحاسمه في جنيف تحدث الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد بنبره القيصر خلال
مقابله مع تلفزيون
عندما نرى ان الولايات المتحده توقفت عن
التهديد والسعي للهجوم وتسليم اسلحه
للارهابيين حينها سنعتبر انه بامكاننا
المضي في العمليه حتى النهايه وانها
مقبوله بالنسبه لسوريا اضاف ان قبوله
التخلي عن اسلحه بلاده الكيميائيه كان
استجابه للمبادره الروسيه وليس تحت تاثير
التهديد الامريكي بالقيام بضربه عسكريه
ضربه ستسعى موسكو الى انتزاع ضمانات من
واشنطن بتخليها عن الفكره مقابل تخلي
الحليف السوري عن سلاحه الكيميائي لا ترى
انقره خيرا في الجهود الروسيه شكك رئيس
الوزراء التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في التزام
دمشق بتعهداتها الاخيره وقال ان نظام
الاسد يحاول كسب الوقت لارتكاب مجازر
جديده اما وزير الخارجيه البريطاني فقد
دعا الى التعامل بحذر مع اي تعهد سوري فهو
في نظره نظام كذب لسنوات بشان مخزون سلاحه
الكيميائي
المؤكد ان قبول واشنطن لعب الشطرانج مع
الروس يعني ان خيار القوه بات بعيدا وخيار
الدبلوماسيه الفاشله على مدى اكثر من
عامين هو الاقرب اما حل الازمه السوريه
فهو رهين التعقيدات المتلاحقه ولزمن اخر
ليس
بقصير ضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من واشنطن لوك
كوفي الباحث في مؤسسه يتج الامريكيه من
موسكو الينا سوبونينا رئيسه قس الشرق
الاوسط في مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه في
روسيا وهنا في الاستديو الكاتب الصحفي عبد
الوهاب بدرخان اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا لو
بدانا من من
واشنطن سيد كوفي ما هي النقاط التي مازالت
تقلق واشنطن في التعامل مع المبادره
الروسيه في الواقع هنا في
واشنطن
نشعر انه ربما لا يمكن الوثوق بالروس حول
هذا ثمت مجموعات كبيره داخل الكونغرس وحتى
في الراي العام الذين يريدون ان يجدوا حلا
سلميا لما يجري في سوريا لا يؤيدون الضربه
العسكريه لكن في الوقت عينه هم حذرون لان
روسيا سوف تقود هذا الحل الدبلوماسي
بالتالي فعلا يجب ان نتوخى الحذر والتفاؤل
ايضا هذا العرض الروسي قد يتمتع ببعض
المصداقيه لكن سوف يتطلب وقتا طويلا اذا
في هذه الحاله سيده سبون ما الذي يمكن ان
يجعل هذا العرض ذي مصداقيه من وجهه النظر
الروسيه روسيا تعتقد بان هذا العرض ادانا
الى النجاح النسبي وهو انه الضربات
العسكريه الامريكيه قد تاجلت اعتمادا على
هذه المبادره فهذا الشيء جيد اما موسكو
تتفاهم بانه
هناك عمل صعب امام الكل الخلافات ما زالت
موجوده الشيطان هو مثل العاده في في
التفاصيل التفاصيل لحتى
الان لم تتبلور بشكل نهائي
ولكن نحن
نرى انه
الخلافات ممكن ان تبدا وهي موجوده اصلا
على سبيل المثال على المجز زمنيه لتنفيذ
هذه المبادره بالعاده تدمير الاسلحه
الكيمياويه يتطلب ليس فقط اشهر
سنوات ويبدو انه في حاله الازمه السوريه
ليس لدينا مثل هذا
الوقت روسيا اعلنت بانه قبل كل شيء على
سوريا ان تنضم
لمنظمه حظر الاسلحه الكيمياويه حتى هذه
الع عمليه هي بحاجه لاشهر نعم في هذه
الحاله سيد عبد الوهاب بدر خان ايه لقاء
جناف بين كيري ولافروف هل هل يمكن ان ان
يذلل هذه ال الهواجس لدى موسكو ولدى
واشنطن في نفس الوقت يعني يفترض اذا كان
الوزيران سيجتمعان على مدى ساعات وخلال
يومين او ثلاثه فمعنى ذلك ان
الطرفين يريدان التوصل الى توافق او اتفاق
على نص ك متكامل يمكن الذهاب به الى مجلس
الامن
ولديهما الخبراء اللازمين لكي يشرحوا كل
النقاط التفصيليه ربما يقع ا يعني خلاف
على عدد من النقاط ولكن طالما ان الوزير
الوزيرين موجودان و هذا يعني ان يعني كل
طرف يريد التوصل الى مثل هذا الاتفاق
لاسبابه الروس لانهم ا استطاعوا ان يلجم
التحرك العسكري الولايات المتحده لانها
استطاعت او تعتبر انها انتزعت من النظام
السوري تنازل كبير ليس فقط من اجل الشعب
السوري وانما خصوصا من
اجل يعني خصوصا اسرائيل لانه اول من دعى
الى تجريد سوريا من السلاح الكيماوي هو هو
اسرائيل اذا الاسباب متوفره ل لكي يكون
هناك اتفاق وحتى الان يبدو ان النظام
السوري يلعب اللعبه بشكل معقول بالنسبه ل
للطرفين
ايضا السيد كوفي في في واشنطن الرئيس
اوباما اعرب عن امله في الوصول الى خطه
قابله للتطبيق قابله للتطبيق هل تعتقد بان
الجدول المراحل الاربعه حتى وان لم تكن
فيه مواعيد الذي طرحته
يعتبر خطه قابله
للتطبيق اعتقد ان النقاط الاربعه التي
اقترحتها روسيا هي خطوه في الاتجاه الصحيح
في الولايات المتحده توقعاتنا عاليه لجهه
السرعه التي يمكن ان تحقق فيها هذه الخطه
والسرعه التي تسمح لنا
باحصاء الاسلحه الكيمياويه ووضعها تحت
الرقابه لكن الروس يدفعون نحو مقاربه اكثر
واقعيه يجب ان نتذكر طبعا ان هذه العمليه
سوف تاخذ وقتا طويلا هنا في الولايات
المتحده الاداره تريد ان ترى نتائج في
اسرع وقت ممكن لكن واقع الامر ان هذا قد
يتطلب اشهر اذا لم يكن سنوات ونحن نتحدث
عن التخلص من 1000 طن من الاسلحه
الكيمياويه وزن ذلك مليونين باوند وذلك من
منطقه تشهد حربا اصلا لن تكون مهمه سهله
وسوف تسترق وقتا طويلا ايضا سيد
كوفي موسكو تريد التوصل الى تسويه خارج
الامم المتحده ومجلس الامن على ما يبدو هل
هل يمكن ان تسيرها واشنطن في
ذلك اعتقد انه حاليا اوباما يريد ان يجد
طريقا كي يجد مخرجا له ايضا بالنسبه
للزاويه التي احرج نفسه فيها فيما يتعلق
بالضربات العسكريه في سوريا ما رايناه
اليوم في جنيف مع المحادثات الثنائيه بين
الوزير لافروف والوزير كاري انما هي في
الاتجاه الصائب ايضا الان ان نجعل
الولايات المتحده وروسيا تتفقان على
الشروط في هذه الصفقه للتخلص من الاسلحه
الكيمياويه في سوريا هذا فعلا جيد حتى لو
كان خارج الامم المتحده ولكن المشكله وهنا
اسال السيده سوبونينا المشكله ان موسكو
تريد التقدم في مبادرتها ولكن كما قال
السيد بوتين لا تريد ان يكون التهديد
باستعمال القوه يبقى مستمرا هذه المعادله
هل هل يمكن ان تحصل عليها
موسكو روسيا قد حصلت على التاجيل الضربه
العسكريه
فهذا بنفسه يعني نجاحا اما التهديدات
الامريكيه
مستمره اعتق من الصعب الان على الامريكان
ان
يتراجع فورا عن هذا
ولكن روسيا
تتقدم وتتفوق على الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
الان في هذه المناورات
ولكني اسمحوا لي ان اتفق معكم على النق
نقطه انه روسيا كما يبدو لكم تريد التسويه
خارج الامم المتحده هذا غير صحيح روسيا
دائما تحترم مجلس الامن والامم المتحده
بالعكس روسيا ضد افعال احديه الجانب
وروسيا دائما تنتقد
امريكا المقصود سيد سوبونينا المقصود
للتوضيح انه خارج التلويح بالفصل السابعه
بالبند السابع بمعنى تجري على اساس تسويه
وليست مساله مفروضه في مجلس
الامن هذا الشيء الثاني انه المسوده التي
طرحتها فرنسا لا ترضي موسكو هذا طبيعي
والجدال في مجلس الامن مستمر روسيا لا
تعتقد بانه هناك حجه الان للجوء للفصل
السابع لانه النظام السوري ابدى رغبته في
في التعاون فالفصل السابع بالعاده هو
اسلوب الضغط في اخر لحظات ح حيث ما ما في
تعاون ولكن الان بالعكس تماما نرى مرونه
كبيره من قبل الحكومه السوريه وحتى موافقه
النظام السوري على المبادره
الكيمياويه وسبب المفاجاه للكل خاصه لجون
كيري نعم هو على اشرت الى المشروع الفرنسي
سيد عبد الوهاب بدر خان الان يوجد مشروع
مقترح قرار فرنسي امريكي بريطاني لكن على
عكس المبادره الروسيه فيه جداول جدول واضح
انه بعد 24 ساعه من صدور القرار تكشف
يعني تنضم روسيا عفوا سوريا لمواعده حضر
الاسلحه الكيميائيه هذا حصل الان هذه يمكن
ان ان نتجاوزه لكن بعد 72 ساعه تكشف كل ما
لديها وخلال 90 يوم تلتزم كل الاطراف
السوريه بتسويه سياسيه من خلال جناف اثنين
يعني ربط الملف الكيميائي بالتسويه هل
تعتقد بان هذا التحرك يمكن ان ترضى عنه
روسيا يعني يمكن ان ترضى اذا اذا اولا اذا
لم يكن هناك لجوء الى البند السابع ويهدد
بعقوبات للنظام السوري وغير ذلك ويمكن ان
تقبل به اذا كان يتوافق مع ال سيتوصل اليه
السيد لافروف مع الوزير كيري اذا يعني
ربما كان هذا التحرك يريد ان
يكمل الاجتماعات في نتائج اجتماعات جنيف
وبنفس الوقت يريد
ان يلفت النظر الى ان مثل هذا الاتفاق في
جنيف يجب ايضا ان يكون له جانب يتعلق
بالحل السياسي اذا كان وجود السيد الاخطر
الابراهيمي ولقاء كيري معه
اشاره في يعني ربما نستطيع القراءه ايضا
بان كيري لافروف ايضا سيكون هناك جانب منه
سياسي في النهايه في بعد بعد الاتفاق على
تفاصيل الاتفاق الكيميائي يمكن النظر في
مساله ما اذا كان هناك امكانيه لتحريك
الحل السياسي اللجه التي كتب بها مقال
الرئيس بوتين في نيويورك تايمز والتصريحات
الروسيه بشكل العام هل هل توحي بان موسكو
وكانها ايه بدات تشعر ب ايه ثقل اضافي في
في المعادله الدوليه الخاصه بسوريا واصبحت
كانها تمعن في الضغط على واشنطن في هذا
الموضوع هناك شعور لدى الرئيس بوتين بان
بانه هو الذي يقود الدبلوماسيه حاليا
وبالتالي هو يوجه نصائح الى الكونغرس
احيانا
اي يتكلم عن النظام العالمي وكانه هو
المسؤول عنه في حين انه يعني سياسته
السوريه لا تتوافق ابدا مع قيم اي
قيم لنظام اخر غير الذي كان يقترحه ايضا
الغرب هناك لهجه انتصار
ولهجه قياده يستغل يستغل فيها رئيس بوتين
الضعف العام الذي يشعر به اوباما نعم في
ضوء هذه التباينات والخلافات المتعلقه
بالمبادره الروسيه كيف يمكن ان نحكم على
طريقه
التعامل في دمشق بخصوص هذه المبادره لنا
عوده لهذا المحور بعد فاصل قصير نرجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نناقش فيها مصير المبادره
الروسيه بشان سوريا في ضوء الجدل حول صيغه
واضحه لتطبيقها سيد كوفي في في واشنطن
المقابله التلفزيونيه الاخيره للرئيس بشار
الاسد واضح انه تحدث فيها
بثقه كبيره في النفس
واشار او حتى بنوع من التحدي عندما قال
بان نحن
قبلنا الاشراف الدولي على الاسلحه
الكيميائيه بناء على طلب روسيا وبان
التهديدات التي اطلقتها واشنطن لم تكن هي
المؤثره وبان لن ننفذ الا اذا الا اذا
وهنا اصبح هو من يشترط الا اذا اوقفت
واشنطن تهديدها باستعمال القوه
واوقفت دعمها لمن وصفهم بالارهابيين هذه
اللهجه لهجه التحدي كيف يمكن ان تتعامل
معها
واشنطن
اعتقد ان الرئيس الاسد كان يقول هذه
الامور للجمهور المحلي كان عليه ان
يبدو الشخص الذي يتحدى امام شعبه ولهذا
الغرض سمعنا منه هذه التعابير لكن هو يعرف
تماما كما الاخرين انه لن يقرر اي شيء في
هذا المجال انهم الروس والامريكيون الذين
سوف يقررون لكن الرئيس الاسد محق عندما
يقول لانه الامر يرتبط بالتاثير الروسي
هذا الذي دفع الاسد الى التخلي عن الاسلحه
الكيمياويه منه تاثير تهديد الولايات
المتحده بالضربه العسكريه لانكم تعرفون في
نهايه المطاف الاداره لرئيس اوباما
والوزير كيري فعلا بذلوا قصاره الجاد لكي
يعبروا عن الى الشعب الامريكي الى ان هذه
الضربه سوف تكون محدوده وصغيره جدا وعندما
نقول ضربه عسكريه صغيره او محدوده هذا لا
يبدو كتهديد بالنسبه لاي شخص بالتالي ارى
ان التغيير في سلوك الاسد انما هو نتيجه
ضغوط مورث من روسيا وروسيا هي التي ادت
الى ذلك وليس اي ولكن مع ذلك هذه اللهجه
التي تحدث بها سيده سوبونينا
هل الاعتداد الروسي ب دبلوماسيتها في
الفتره الماضيه مثل ما اشار السيد بدر خان
انتقل بدوره الى حليفها
الاسد لا انا اعتقد انه الان
هو الامر في دبلوماسيه
و في الرايه العام الروسي ايضا الراي
العام الروسي يعترض بشده على توجيه
الضربات على سوريا وهناك الان اعتزاز
بنجاح وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ف بال اضافه
الى انه روسيا تفهم بانه هي ليست وحدها في
في هذا الصف
انتم لا تنسون بانه التصويت في البرلمان
البريطاني ايضا لعب دوره الراي العام في
امريكا ايضا غير مؤيد لتوجيه هذه الضربات
تردد اوباما كان واضح للكل والمعروف
و مبادئ اوباما ايضا تتناقض مع نظريه
الحرب كل هذا روسيا اخذت بعين الاعتبار
لكي تلعب هذا الدور الان ولكن كلام الاسد
سيده سوبونينا عندما يقول لن لن ننفذ الا
اذا اوقفت واشنطن تهديدها واوقفت دعمها
للارهابيين كما قال هل هل موسكو تشاطره
ايضا نفس هذا التصور بمعنى لا يمكن للخطه
ان ان ان تتقدم الا بهذه
الاشتراطات تصور انه هذه الخطه ممكن ان
تتقدم والان لافروف و
يعملان على هذا الشيء ولكن مثل هذه
التحديدات حتبقى ما بين العراقيل لتنفيذ
هذه الخطه فنحن نفهم بانه التنفيذ حيكون
في غايه الصعوبه
هذا ليست صعوبه وحيده الحرب الدائره في
سوريا بنفسها هي تشكل قا كبيرا لتنفيذ هذه
المبادره لانه هذه المبادره تتطلب عوده
المفتشين الدوليين لسوريا وهم عده مرات
تعرضوا الى اطلاق النار ف بالتاكيد انه
هذه الخطه
هتتطلب خطوات اخرى منها دعوه لعوده الجنفا
اثنين منها مفاوضات السلام ما بين ممثلي
النظام والمعارضه
و ممكن فيما بعد حتى الهدنه حتكون مطلوبه
نعم سيد بدر خان قبل قليل اشرت الى ان
النظام في دمشق الى حد ما ادار الموضوع
بطريقه معقوله وجيده ال المعجبون بنظام
الاسد يكتبون قصائد غزل هذه الايام على
اساس ان هناك حنكه وحكمه في
اداره اللعبه وبان الاسد تقريبا شبه منتصر
وليس محشورا الى اي مدى هذه الخلافات بين
موسكو وواشنطن توفر مجال لل للرئيس الاسد
للتحرك لا انا ما قصدته عندما قلت انه
يتصرف بشكل معقول هو انه يتصرف بشكل
يخدم الوفد الروسي لكي يتوصل الى اتفاق هو
لا يلعب بمساله الاستجابه للاقتراح الروسي
ولكن يريد ان يصور ان تخليه عن السلاح
الكيماوي هو انتصار له كل كل الاعلام
حاليا كل المسؤولين السوريين يتكلمون بهذه
اللهجه وبنفس الوقت هو ايضا اراد ان يقول
بانه استجاب للاقتراح الروسي وليس
للتهديدات
ولكن الاقتراح الروسي جاء بسبب التهديدات
وبسبب ان ان روسيا خشيت انه العمل العسكري
يفلت الازمه من يدها لانها هي التي تديرها
عمليا وبالتالي هذا هذا الرئيس تحدث وكانه
ليس لديه شعب يحاسبه وليس لديه احد يحاسبه
هو جاء بالكيماوي لكي ير ضع اسرائيل كما
قال فاذا به يستخدم هذا هذا السلاح ضد ضد
شعبه
وبالتالي المهم عنده ان يبقى هذا كل كل ما
ولكن هل هل هو في في موقع يسمح له ب ان
يقول سننفذ ولا ننفذ او ننفذ اذا فعلت
واشنطن كذا وكذا هل هو في في موقع يسمح له
بفرض هذه الاشتراطات ليس ليس في موقع يسمح
له بفرض اي شرط هو س سيمتثل لما توافق
عليه موسكو وبالتالي
اي هو سيلعب فقط عند التنفيذ عند التنفيذ
س سيكون له كلام لان لانه لن لن يكشف كل
الاماكن التي يخزن فيها سيقول ان هناك
مناطق لا نستطيع الوصول اليها سيلعب
100000 لعبه على المفتشين لكي يطول العمل
ويكسب وقت و وكسب الوقت هو اتهام اردوغان
قال بان كل ما يجري هو كسب للوقت للنظام
الس هل تعتقد بان فعلا هذا اكبر كسب قبل
كل شيء يعني ولكن لم يعد يخدمه كثيرا
اعتقد انه كسب الوقت نعم لان اذا اذا سمعت
اليوم ان جون كيري قال انه النظام السوري
معه شهر لكي يكشف
اي ما هو ما لديه فهذا يعني ان كل ما كل
الجو تبع
العمل العسكري خلاص سيتلاشى نهائيا بعد
شهر لن يستطيع اوباما او ادارته ان يتحدث
عن اي عمل عسكري نعم شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتب
الصحفي عبد الوهاب بدر خان شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من واشنطن لو كوفي الباحث في مؤسسه
ايتنج وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من موسكو الينا
سوبونينا رئيسه قسم الشرق الاوسط في مركز
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه من واشنطن بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه في امان
[موسيقى]
الله